[Música]
las tropas de moscú avanzan en el este
ucraniano controlando cada vez más
territorio severodonezk está bajo
bombardeos constantes y los pro rusos
afirman que ya se tomaron al imán aunque
el ministerio defensa ucraniano dice que
allí todavía resisten algunos distritos
la iglesia católica de italia
investigará los abusos sexuales que
cometieron los clérigos en los últimos
dos años mientras que sólo harán un
análisis de los casos reportados desde
el 2000 víctimas y activistas mostraron
su descontento con una protesta en el
vaticano
los países del alba se reúnen en la
habana este viernes en la salida de la
bolivariana están los gobiernos de cuba
nicaragua y venezuela entre otros países
a los que eeuu podrían no invitar a la
cumbre de las américas esta reunión será
un contrapeso lo analizaremos en minutos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
el uso del nudo de nuevo maría clara
calle y empezamos con la actualidad
ucraniana las tropas rusas han logrado
el mayor avance en semanas y cada vez
golpean más fuerte a las ciudades que
siguen en pie en la región del donbass
los militares de moscú tienen a la urbe
de severodonezk rodeada y según el
alcalde de la ciudad al menos un 60% de
los edificios residenciales han sido
destruidos y 1500 personas han muerto
desde el inicio de la guerra además
alrededor de 13.000 habitantes
permanecen dentro de esta ciudad una de
las pocas de la provincia de lugansk que
no ha caído más al oeste los rusos están
a punto de tomarse la ciudad ferroviaria
del imán los prorrusos aseguran que ya
están totalmente controlando la urbe
inicialmente el portavoz de la
presidencia ucraniana afirmó lo mismo
pero luego el ministerio de defensa
sostuvo que hay algunos distritos que
resisten escuchemos en dirección al imán
los defensores ucranianos están
contrarrestando los intentos del enemigo
de empujar a nuestras tropas desde las
partes noroeste y sureste del imán y
presionar un avance sobre es lo bianco
rusia también controla parte del sur
ucraniano especialmente las salidas al
mar el presidente del país vladimir
selenski denunció que moscú bloqueó el
acceso a los puertos del mar negro y ya
tiene el control en el mar de azov
después de tomarse mariupol según el
mandatario la consecuencia es que las
rutas comerciales de ucrania están
cerradas y no han podido exportar 22
millones de toneladas de granos y así
rusia está presionando a través de los
alimentos
creo que rusia ha apostado liberada
mente la crisis alimentaria para
aumentar la dependencia de otros países
sobre sí mismos y hacer el acceso a los
alimentos otro factor de presión presión
a la política global
cuanto antes se liberen nuestras tierras
de los ocupantes más seguras de hecho
será la protección de las personas en
todo el mundo
deseos agresivos de aquellos que quieren
seguir políticas coloniales como en los
viejos tiempos su ley o si ya llegaron a
la capital de guinea ecuatorial los
líderes de la unión africana un día
antes de la cumbre extraordinaria que
tendrán para discutir la situación
humanitaria del continente
estado ya comenzaron a hablar en malabo
sobre la lucha contra el extremismo en
áfrica la sequía y cómo detener los
golpes militares es que en menos de dos
años ha habido cinco derrocamientos en
el continente en cuanto a los efectos de
la crisis climática una de las
situaciones que más preocupa es la del
norte de burkina faso donde varias
personas se han desplazado por la falta
de producción agrícola y también por la
violencia
en otras noticias la asociación nacional
del rifle de eeuu inauguró este viernes
su reunión anual en houston texas el
mismo estado en donde el pasado martes
hubo el tiroteo más mortífero que ha
habido en una escuela del país en casi
una década cristóbal vázquez nuestro
enviado especial a igualdad y nos habló
previamente del lobby de la asociación
nacional del rifle y cuáles son los
senadores que reciben más dinero
el senador por texas muy polémico a
nivel nacional es el que más recibe
dinero por parte de las empresas de
armas en eeuu y el lobby de armas que es
un nuevo los más grandes en este país
estarán también el gobernador de dakota
del sur kristi noem en la gobernadora de
el gobernador perdón de carolina del
norte también marc globovisión y estará
obviamente donald trump es de resaltar
que en balde llegará el domingo el
presidente joe biden estará acompañando
a las víctimas se hará una nueva iglesia
también en esa ciudad y pues los
funerales las empresas funerarias han
dicho públicamente que no van a cobrarle
a las familias de las víctimas de balde
precisamente después de este tiroteo que
deja 19 niños muertos ni dos profesores
también
en cuba se realizará este viernes la
reunión de la alianza bolivariana para
los pueblos de nuestra américa conocida
como alba allí asistirán los gobiernos
de cuba venezuela y nicaragua que hasta
ahora han sido excluidos de la cumbre de
las américas que se realizará en eeuu
conectamos a esta hora con amauri
chamorro estratega en comunicación
política bienvenido señor chamorro a
france24
la habana anunció el encuentro del alba
apenas esta misma semana y un día antes
de que el presidente cubano miguel díaz
canel afirmara que no irá a la cumbre de
las américas en los ángeles en este
sentido esta convocatoria es una
retaliación a la exclusión que ha hecho
eeuu al no querer invitar a los tres
países que mencionamos
bueno no diría que es una retaliación
sino que es una acción natural de un
bloque de países de un continente que no
puede ser excluido de un proceso como un
encuentro continental ya estas
decisiones unilaterales por parte de los
eeuu no caben más en un mundo como el
que vivimos hoy o sea ya y américa
latina se ha levantado vemos el apoyo
del presidente
méxico desde argentina a los países que
han sido excluidos inclusive por el
mismo luis arce de bolivia diciendo que
no participaría en la cumbre acaso no
está en los países no sean invitados sea
una forma de natural de exponer una
articulación política que demuestra una
soberanía del continente hacia una
postura injerencista de los eeuu y que
se espera que ocurra en la reunión en
cuba
es una reunión que de alguna forma tiene
también un trasfondo económico no
recordando que venezuela es la mayor
reserva de petróleo del planeta logró
articular en torno de lo que es el alba
casi toda centroamérica y el caribe para
una soberanía energética de esos países
y no depender más
económicamente y también nos no sucumbir
ante la presión de los eeuu por ejemplo
en momentos de votación dentro de la
asamblea desde los estados americanos
entonces yo creo que en este momento hay
una definición tanto en materia política
de postura hacia el gobierno de joe
biden pero también de articulación
económica entre estos países que por
menores que seas también tienen son
países que votan en la onu son países
que votan en instituciones
multilaterales y que de alguna manera se
demuestran actuando en bloque para poder
ya así posicionarse internacionalmente
ante ese tipo de medidas y recordemos
que el alba nació en 2004 como un
proyecto paralelo para integrar américa
sin la presencia de estados unidos y
especialmente de sus tratados de libre
comercio pero que tanto se puede avanzar
en política y en economía de la región
sin la presencia de este país y también
sin varios latinoamérica como chile
argentina brasil o colombia que no hacen
parte del alma
bueno en el mundo el mundo multipolar es
importante que los países puedan actuar
en bloque cuando cuando existe una
unidad de países que no tienen la
capacidad de negociar por ejemplo en
materia de comercio exterior con la
unión europea con asia o con los eeuu es
mejor trabajar en bloque imagínate lo
que sería un país pequeño como 'el
salvador' negociando solo solo con la
unión europea o un país como uruguay
ahora si tú pones a toda américa latina
integrada bajo un concepto de unidad
para permitir mejores condiciones
económicas e inclusive también posturas
políticas internacionales para defender
la soberanía de los países es muy
importante yo creo que el mundo está
cambiando américa latina también está
cambiando
nuevamente se se alinean los movimientos
progresistas con las victorias últimas
victorias electorales y ahora también en
el caso de colombia con el despunte de
gustavo petro que puede ser inclusive
que gane en primera vuelta entonces ese
equilibrio de la región es importante y
el alba ha nacido en 2004 como respuesta
al alca no que era la propuesta del área
de libre comercio
américa en un proyecto neoliberal de bus
que se cae frente a un proyecto de
inclusión de integración al
latinoamericano con un enfoque hacia
nuestra propia región realmente tiene en
sí y juega un rol importante de
articulación en bloque de países que no
tendrían ningún peso internacional se
actuarían solos entonces es importante
considerar esto en este momento político
de américa latina donde por ejemplo en
el caso de colombia puede ganar usado
petro en el caso de brasil puede ganar
el presidente lula boris gana en chile
vuelve luís arce
vuelve en la izquierda
boliviano gracias a mauri y chamorro por
estar con nosotros en france24
a ustedes en otras noticias activistas
contra los abusos sexuales protestaron
en el vaticano para exigirle a la
iglesia católica del país que actúe en
las investigaciones de los crímenes y es
que después de una semana de reuniones
los obispos católicos de italia
anunciaron que encargaran un informe
sobre los abusos sexuales que cometieron
los clérigos únicamente en los últimos
dos años mientras que los casos que van
del 2000 al 2021 sólo tendrán un
análisis según informó el cardenal mateo
zuppi grupos de víctimas y activistas
expresaron su frustración pedían una
investigación independiente general que
se remontará al menos a una parte del
siglo pasado como pasó en francia y en
alemania
le ha sido debilitada
estamos aquí por la inmovilidad de la
iglesia pero sobre todo porque el estado
no interviene por alguna razón parece
que el estado está dejando que la
iglesia maneje la situación la
contradicción de esto es que la iglesia
es técnicamente la parte acusada la
parte que se supone que debe reparar los
abusos sexuales del clero
necesitamos un organismo imparcial en
este caso el estado para manejar la
situación
en cambio el estado ha sido la única
parte importante ausente en todo este
asunto desde hace años únicos grandes
ente disputa cuesta problemática por
maldad en colombia hace votar a la
primera vuelta de las presidenciales
este domingo y la economía ha sido una
de las preocupaciones constantes de los
votantes el 40 por ciento de los
colombianos vive bajo el umbral de
pobreza y según el banco mundial
colombia es el segundo país más desigual
de américa latina los detalles los
tienen daniela blandón y benjamin el mar
fue el epicentro del comercio de
esclavos y uno de los puertos más
importantes para los españoles durante
la conquista siglos después la joya
turística de colombia cartagena es uno
de los motores económicos y el lugar
seguro para la inversión en un país tan
rico en recursos como desigual héctor
trujillo es miembro de la élite de
antaño y fue gerente regional de la
asociación nacional de empresarios y el
poder empresarial está en manos de
empresas extranjeras esta empresa están
direccionadas tanto en su parte
económica como en su parte política
desde el centro de colombia para él en
plena campaña electoral la política para
los empresarios tradicionalmente de
derecha pasa a un segundo plano si de
dinero se trata de los grandes
conglomerados con tal de quedarse pactan
con crecer
y la clase media la que estar sufriendo
y el empresario intermedio para ser
testigos de esa creciente inversión
basta con visitar las viejas casonas de
la perla del caribe hoy convertidas en
hostales hoteles boutique y lujosos
restaurantes
ya des martínez pasa la mayor parte de
sus días en hesemann y el otrora sector
más pobre de la cartagena amurallada hoy
protagonista del boom turístico en
españa según ella los recursos que van y
vienen no los llegan a beneficiar a
todos la riqueza como tal
no se ve reflejada de 100% la mayoría de
la gente de barrio la mamá se constituye
porque no consiguen un empleo porque no
hay una capacitación porque hay veces
que pronto quieren trabajar quieren
digamos que salir adelante para unai
oportunidades su verdadera realidad como
la de muchos otros miles de cartageneros
al servicio de la industria y del
turismo está en la periferia unas 80 mil
personas habitan en este barrio en donde
la pobreza y la abstención electoral van
de la mano al área ya desconfía en que
con su voto contribuir a que la
situación algún día cambie su tierra ir
opina lo contrario la gente por aquí
casi la mayoría de la gente no vota
porque los políticos no hacen nada por
este barrio entonces a veces la gente le
da miedo
según el banco mundial colombia es el
segundo país más desigual de américa
latina después de brasil como bien lo
prueba el diario vivir en 2 cartagenas
reflejo de dos colombias distintas una
con un desarrollo a todo vapor y otro
que siente que jamás saldrá de la
pobreza el g7 se trazó una nueva meta
ambiental descarbonizar el sector
eléctrico para el año 2035 lo que
implica que los siete países miembros
deben eliminar gradualmente el carbón a
más tardar en 2030 todo esto con el
propósito de reducir las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero
desde berlín donde se reúnen los
ministros de las naciones del g7 también
anunciaron que los vehículos eléctricos
dominarían las ventas de automóviles
nuevos para fines de la década y por
primera vez reconocieron la necesidad de
dar más dinero a los países en
desarrollo para hacer frente a las
pérdidas y a los daños y han sido
causados por la crisis climática
castells siempre habrá calentamiento
global todavía puede ser posible para
nosotros arreglar los errores del pasado
es imposible para nosotros deshacer los
el calentamiento global cero ya no es
una opción la única cuestión que estamos
discutiendo aquí es se frenará el
calentamiento global mediante una acción
política decisiva en los próximos años y
no en los próximos 30 años sino en los
próximos 4 5 8 10 años de tal manera que
entonces tengamos siquiera opción de
acción su aparato trabajan desnudistas
en sus sets así llegamos al final de las
noticias pero los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con france24 y visiten
nuestra página web france24 puntocom nos
vemos en minutos
[Música]